is that essentially your biggest problem
with the red pill Community is that it's
all negative it's all uh sure and it's
all what could happen bad and and they
have to be real there's an incentive
structure for it I'm I shared some of
these people these numbers I'm I'm gonna
share some of these numbers with you
I did a video because it's so funny
because the red pill Community those
kind of guys they're they're so fickle
and they they love you when you bash
women but the mo but the moment you
share any objectivity showing the both
sides now all of a sudden they're
demonizing you right so so it's very
interesting that I do videos that are
critical of modern men and modern women
I try to be as balanced as possible I
know for a fact my my content will be
weak if it's in Balance so I like to do
as balance as possible I did a video a
couple years a couple months ago called
the um
um
um why women today are not marriageable
I did that video talking about some of
the principles that I believe are true
why women have issues and we can go on
that for days that video did over half a
million views in two weeks I did another
video called the sad reality beautiful
women talking about how it sometimes
attractive women have an air air of
entitlement about themselves that makes
them difficult relationship another
video half a million views the reality
of the matter is in that month alone I
told the guys understand it I'm just
being transparent and honest with those
two videos and then Candace Owens coming
on the podcast talking about the
problems with modern women we made 55
000 that month 55 000 just doing a few
videos and I know almost everybody in
the space and everyone shows me their
money and I'm and I was making the least
of what everybody else is making
but when I do the other content Adam the
more balanced content there's not Clicks
in it there's not views in it what type
of content like like let's say if I was
do a video about hey guys here here are
signs like let's say the five things to
pick in a wife
those kind of guys don't want to hear
that they want to hear five things wrong
with women today that's what they want
to hear they want to hear more of the
negative stuff they want they want it
reinforced like CNN like CNN does not
want to hear five things great about
Donald Trump hell no Cena don't want to
hear that give me five things wrong with
Trump and so to me when you're doing
balance content even when you're doing
male Improvement stuff because I think
there's a difference between
um real male Improvement because it has
to improved the lives of men Fitness
emotional health spiritual growth what
are you doing that that don't get views
and and Views in my comments would
always talk about this at dang the girl
stuff gets 10x abuse of the male
Improvement stuff and and also when
fresh and fit will tell you the same
thing when they do their Finance stuff
they've always told me I don't know if
things have changed they've told me when
they do Finance dudes don't watch that
but they want to watch the girl stuff
right yeah look at the girls that they
they have the fresh and fit you know
I've talked with them and I told them I
would love to do a one-on-one but I I'm
definitely the exception yeah also I'm
not great for that but they bring girls
on there that are very I don't wanna I
don't want to make it about first and
fit because nothing some respect I don't
like to criticize anybody who's not in
the room I was just bringing them up
about the point of they told me when
they do Finance so other guys don't
watch them so my thing is that there's
not a financial incentive so if you're a
content creator Adam and I'll give you
example and you know if you do this type
of content you're making fifty thousand
dollars a month you do the other you
make six which one are you gonna lean
towards yeah of course yeah so so as a
content creator
um who like I I this is our first time
we're meeting in person sure but you
strike me as a person who's just telling
it like it is based on your life
experience okay you don't seem like the
type of person who's like well I could
say this for clicks but this does better
but there must be a little bit of
element in that maybe how you do
thumbnails or titles absolutely so our
face is he's knocking very
impassionately making some very valid
points that's what he's talking about is
absolutely true but what we have to
understand is when you're doing content
you have to kind of pick a lane in the
genre I mean if you go to only fans and
you start wearing a mother gown you
ain't gonna get no clue hey there's a
market there's a market
there's a market for it but I don't see
you doing that tomorrow but the reality
is this
um I have 12 YouTube channels all right
and I if not all of them are this
content and it is true those channels
struggle if I'm doing something else but
that's the reality of the situation it
would be like
um the I love the example that he gave
you wouldn't sell a house like this of
course no why salesmen would give you
the negatives they would tell you
something in order to make the
commission so in essence he's shooting
himself in the foot but on my side I
have to keep a lane and make sure people
understand what that is of course if I
crossed over and I brought balance uh
sure it might fall flat on my audience
because they may not be interested in
that however I'm gonna say this and I'm
gonna add this many times if I brought
on a female content creator and sat down
and had an interview in a one-on-one
most of the conversation if we did bring
the balance will start leaning over to
her and people know this they watch
television they see movies stuff like
that every one point that they would
make towards a man to get him to pay
attention they'd have to make five or
ten points for the woman so it's kind of
like hey you know yeah CGA you raining
down on the head over here today and
then they would tell me to back off all
right come on man we can't let them feel
a certain way and that's kind of just
how it works so I have to stay in that
lane to be
um honest to the to my Approach the
minute I bring it over to the other side
then the other side's gonna lean and
I'll just add this if I really wanted to
make money I'd be out here praising the
woman I'll be out here uplifting the
woman I'll Be A Millionaire I think it
goes back to personal accountability too
though people people consume if you're
going to sit there and consume the same
cut that's their thing personal
accountability I you know I I consume
content that I generally align with but
I'm also very wise enough to know I
should also consume content that
counteracts with what I believe because
otherwise then you never learn and I
think that's I don't think there's
anything wrong with staying like you
said in your lane you got your Niche and
that's kind of beautiful choices oh one
more thing if people wanted to watch
Finance if I came on and I'd do some
Finance related videos but I don't have
a finance degree I'm just offering
advice if people want that there's how
many billions of YouTube channels out
there they can find somebody else for
that and that's probably why my finance
video won't get clicks they know my lane
and they'll want to enter this
information people need to make sure
they're to have an accountability well
to Circle back to if he says and I love
how passion you are bro life is all
about balance okay if you're living in
Echo Chambers or if you're in extremists
to any and whether it's politically
whether it's financially you know
whether it's romantically any sort of
extremist has major blind spots major
blind spots so striking the balance
whether it's the East and West whether
it's the pros and cons of marriage I
think is important and it's a very
nuanced discussion a lot of people oh
this is the way it is it's black and
white like Ali mentioned there's a lot
of gray area in all this so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]